on this Wednesday night six months of
Russia's war in Ukraine
the deadly new attack as The Invasion
collides with Ukraine's Independence Day
how Putin has unintentionally propped up
Ukraine on the world stage a fresh
perspective from Canada's first
indigenous Supreme Court nominee I hope
my different path will allow it to make
a lasting contribution Michelle
obonsawin's experience and expertise
returning stolen treasure the London
Museum righting a wrong more than a
century later plus the swipe and swap
mystery at an Ottawa Hotel it was beyond
our wildest imagination Sir Winston
Churchill's portrait poached
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser
good evening thanks for joining us today
an anniversary Russia has been trying to
stop Ukraine is marking 31 years since
it gained independence from the Soviet
Union but this Independence Day is
unlike any other a grim One In A Country
Shattered by Russia's Invasion which
began six months ago to the day
the harsh reality of the war doesn't
stop but in its face Ukraine remains
strong
six months of survival solidarity and
sacrifice standing up to one of the
biggest armies in the world today in
leviv young boys carry the Ukrainian
flag during a public ceremony while
mourners pay their respects residents in
Kiev gathered in the destroyed Central
Square children playing on burnt out
Russian tanks as Jeff sempler reports in
our top story tonight it's a celebration
of Independence as the country braces
for more brutal attacks
Universal real greatest on Ukraine's
Independence Day the cost of their
freedom was on full display a funeral
for a Ukrainian Soldier one of around 9
000 killed along with thousands more
civilians over the past six months
a new nation was born on February 24th
not born but Reborn the president said
we will not give up or forget
the scaled down annual celebration in
the capital was drowned out by air raid
sirens
amid fears that Russia might Mark the
occasion with an attack Russian missile
strikes were reported across the country
including one targeting a train station
in Southeastern Ukraine killing at least
15 people and injuring dozens more
Russia is a terrorist State this
Canadian Ukrainian member of Ukraine's
territorial Defense Force says with each
attack ukrainians grow more defiant
Russia Now controls around 20 percent of
Ukraine's territory mostly in the South
and the East but opinion polls show a
growing number of ukrainians around 90
percent don't want to cede any territory
to Russia even if it meant ending the
war whenever the the Russians and Putin
double down to to in their in their
terrorist
activities uh you know Ukraine is just
stiffened their resolve but while
Ukraine's resolve remains steadfast
there are fears International attention
is waning there is donor fatigue this
Canadian in Kiev is scrambling to help
rebuild some of the hardest hit
communities before the winter in several
months it's going to get very cold in
people's homes when they don't have
Windows they don't have an energy Supply
to head off the dwindling donations one
Ukrainian volunteer launched a new
fundraising campaign donors can add
personalized messages onto Ukrainian
rockets and other weapons before they're
fired at Russian forces when we stopped
getting donations from other people and
we decided to try it this Canadian
purchased a message as a birthday
present for his Ukrainian friend
is he from Ukraine
they've raised more than three hundred
thousand dollars so far it's a great way
of
you know supporting the troops on the
front line and that support will be
required for the long haul a war that
many thought might last six days has
dragged on for six months with no end in
sight Jeff Semple Global News
according to the U.N Refugee agency
European countries have taken in more
than 6.8 million refugees from Ukraine
since the War Began about 6.6 million
people are displaced inside the country
nearly one-third of the population so
far more than 74 thousand ukrainians
have arrived in Canada with the
government vowing to accept an unlimited
number
when The Invasion began as Jeff pointed
out many thought Kiev would fall in days
but Putin appeared to misread the global
situation with one miscalculation after
another and as Eric Sorensen reports the
consequences of his brutal War have made
it easy for supporters to stick by
Ukraine as a smoky Haze hung over Moscow
on this defining anniversary for Ukraine
Vladimir Putin tried to change the
subject
he spoke of forest fires not the fires
of War he set Ablaze exactly six months
ago
his military operation was supposed to
be Swift and decisive it was just
Putin's first miscalculation
but it has been a massive failure for
Vladimir Putin and his machine Putin
also misjudged the unity of the West the
sanctions that have hit Russia hard he
sold short NATO's resolve this is an
historic day which expanded its
membership and continues to finance
high-end Weaponry giving the ukrainians
a Fighting Chance Steve
is really compensating for some of those
numeric superiorities that Putin counted
on and as global leaders elevated the
little-known Ukrainian President Putin
is seeing the West's commitment to a
world order that he underestimated
Jordan has got to see
God's sake this man cannot remain power
that however remains an open question
Russians who oppose Putin and the war
have been largely silenced it's the one
dubious distinction for Putin his grip
on Power and propaganda in Russia is
unyielding Vladimir recruiting is really
relying on the violent repression of any
sort of criticism any criticism of his
war and on on domestic disinformation uh
to brainwash his people into supporting
the war
one other inadvertent consequence Russia
cannot undo it's made Ukraine relevant
in the world
people their culture who is unfamiliar
with this flag now in the eyes of so
many Ukraine is worth saving and Russia
will have to answer for what it's done
is coming out of this war with
diminished status in the world at some
point Russian Society will have to
reckon with uh the guilt and
responsibility for waging uh this
aggressive illegal War Russia's
Unforgettable brutality has achieved
something Vladimir Putin never intended
he's made it hard for the world to ever
abandon Ukraine Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto
the United States is set to send its
biggest military aid package to Ukraine
since the Russian invasion began
President Joe Biden says his country
will send nearly 3 billion dollars in
arms including ammunition Vehicles air
defenses artillery drones and more and
unlike previous Aid that was focused on
Ukraine's immediate needs this package
is aimed at reinforcing the country's
long-term defenses so far the U.S has
sent over 10 billion dollars in military
aid
Michelle obonsoin will make history
early next month when she becomes the
first indigenous person to sit on the
Supreme Court today she appeared before
a parliamentary committee answering
questions about her career experience
and Judicial philosophy as Mercedes
Stevenson reports obon's appointment is
being hailed as a landmark moment for
our country incorporating an indigenous
perspective and lived experience into
the top Court
in a historic moment Michelle Obama
sawin greeted a parliamentary Committee
in the Abenaki language every nominee to
the Supreme Court has followed a
different path to get there
and I hope my different path will allow
it to make a lasting contribution to the
court a bilingual franco-ontario Abenaki
from odinak First Nation obonsoan
remembers being told as a young person
that maybe law wasn't for a girl like
her but that only made her more
determined Justice Minister David
lametti says the appointment is a
critical step forward the Court's legit
is Missy is enhanced when Canadians see
themselves represented on the court
obonsawin has served as an Ontario
Superior Court Judge since 2017. even on
the bench she experienced racism in
Canada's justice system I could hear a
lawyer speaking to a junior lawyer and
at one point I hear that lawyer say oh
she's a native Indian she's our
Pocahontas of the north mental health
law human rights and Privacy Law are
just a few of the areas that obons win
has expertise in she's also an expert in
the gladu principles which resulted for
from a Supreme Court decision that lower
courts must consider an indigenous
offender's background when sentencing
them she's going to bring
the indigenous
side of things to to the Supreme Court
she's lived it she knows it Carol
McBride of the Native women's
Association of Canada believes having an
indigenous person on Canada's top court
is essential for sound judgments
especially in areas like compensation
self-governance and Indigenous land
claims if there's a decision to be made
about our rights we need to be in the
room and and I think that Justice obons
win represents that for for the first
time ever in the Court's uh entire
history and while this is just one
appointment formsma says she hopes this
is the beginning of real change in
Canada's legal system and will inspire a
new generation of indigenous lawyers
Mercedes Stevenson Global News
Ottawa
our CMP commissioner Brenda lucky took
the witness stand today for her second
day of testimony at the Nova Scotia Mass
killing inquiry Canada's top mount he
said that when 22 people lost their
lives in 2020 the nation lost trust in
the RCMP but as Callum Smith reports
lucky is vowing to do better and has
apologized for not meeting people's
expectations
Ryan Farrington lost his parents in the
April 2020 killings in Nova Scotia he
traveled from Ontario to Halifax to see
the testimony of our CMP commissioner
Brenda Lucky in person but his
frustrations are growing
are any of our you know suggestions that
come out of this inquiry are going to be
implemented during Lucky's second day on
the stand she was asked why I took RCMP
nearly 19 hours to search kabaquid Court
in portapick where five of the 22
victims were eventually found especially
given recommendations outlined in a
report from mayor Thorpe Alberta where
four RCMP officers were killed in 2005.
I have a commitment to you I have a
commitment to the families we will look
into this we will figure out why that
policy wasn't followed I can't undo the
past but I surely can change the future
this other reviews and lack of completed
internal RCMP review of its response to
the Nova Scotia Massacre raising
concerns and everyone makes mistakes we
understand that these people are are not
just uniforms they're people and and
that's an issue but it's difficult to to
believe that changes are going to be
made when it appears clear that the
powers that be are more interested in
deflecting rather than actually
addressing the issue Lockheed pointed to
a National Emergency Alert policy
adopted after the fact but when it comes
to training can you tell me specifically
are you aware of any plans to review
training or heavy review training in
regards to this mass casualty
not specifically and not yet obviously
we're waiting some of that is waiting
until we get the report lucky says
staffers are following inquiry
proceedings and will review concerns she
admits The Killing Rampage has shattered
people's trust in the force and wants to
repair it I want to apologize for the
RCMP but I you know in such a way that
we weren't what you expected us to be
and I don't think we were what you
wanted us to be or what you needed us to
be the inquiry's final report is due
November 1st I promised myself I
promised my kids
um that my parents death their
grandparents death
will not go without somebody
speaking for them
um to get answers you know to find out
the truth answers he says that haven't
come so far Calum Smith Global News
Halifax
a deadly disaster in Pakistan
coming up the flood-ravaged country
please for help
Pakistan is appealing for international
Health as it struggles to cope with
torrential rain since mid-june flash
floods triggered by an abnormally heavy
monsoon season have displaced about 50
000 and killed more than 900 people 126
people were killed in the past 48 Hours
according to the National disaster
Management Authority most of them women
and children and the flooding is
exacerbating Pakistan's economic crisis
a frightening situation for firefighters
in Portugal where powerful winds whipped
a forest fire into a fire tornado the
fast-moving funnel of fire and smoke was
caught on camera in a national park in
the Northeast part of the country so far
this summer more than 87 thousands of
hectares of land in Portugal has been
burnt that represents a full one percent
of the country's entire area
Thailand is tightening security as
protesters call on the country's prime
minister to resign and as a Court
decides whether or not his time in
office is up
the main opposition filed a petition
Monday arguing the prime minister's time
as military Chief should count toward
the eight-year term limit there priyut
chenocha has been suspended from
official duties he himself launched a
coup in 2014 overthrowing the country's
democratically elected government he was
set at the military for five years and
then continued on as prime minister
after winning the election in 2019 an
election that pro-democracy campaigners
say was rigged
long threatened by human activity the
gentle Marine Mammal the dugong is now
functionally extinct in southern China
also known as the sea cow dugongs have
inhabited China's Southern waters for
hundreds of years researchers say that
widespread habitat loss hunting and
water pollution have all contributed to
their demise the species was classified
as a protected animal in the region in
1988 but the authors of a new study say
they were unable to find any evidence
that the creatures still remain
they don't belong in a museum ahead the
efforts to return stolen artifacts to
their rightful place
members of the niska First Nation
community in British Columbia traveled
to Scotland this week to begin the
process of returning a totem pole taken
from them almost a century ago that trip
comes as museums all around the world
reassess items in their Collections and
consider how they were taken in the
first place as Redmond Shannon reports
some of the thousands of bronze
artifacts stolen from Nigeria in 1897
are now heading back home too
the bronze casters of Benin City Nigeria
for centuries their craft has been
passed down through generations but
thousands of the most famous Benin
bronzers dating back to the 1200s were
stolen by British colonizers in 1897.
each of the objects so taken away
represented an ancestor in captivity not
just an artwork the Benin bronzers ended
up in museums around the world more than
900 are still here in the British museum
but now there is a movement from some to
return them it was wrong to take the
bronzes it was wrong to keep them
Germany is sending back more than a
thousand some British universities and
smaller museums are doing the same for
curators in Nigeria it's a homecoming
and we're happy about it like I said the
ancestors are returning many museums in
the west have argued that items would
get lost stolen or damaged if if
returned to Nigeria on the contrary
experts say that is often what happens
when they're taken away we have examples
across the world where so many museums
can't even say how many of the Benin
items they hold in the collection
because there is not transparency about
what's in the storerooms the Canadian
Museum of History says its intent is to
eventually return its two Benin bronzers
back to Nigeria at the same time museums
around the world have been making moves
to return artifacts and remains to First
nations in Canada this week members of
the niska First Nation visited the
national museum of Scotland to begin the
process of returning a stolen totem pole
Professor Dan Hicks says all museums
need to look closer at their collections
we can't be you know treating one form
of theft in in the rightful way while
hiding away these other issues in the
storerooms OR refusing to speak about
them after a century degrees of theft
the process to return artifacts of
living cultures to their rightful homes
is one that is going to take decades
Redmond Shannon Global News London
Hotel Heist how did this Priceless
portrait in Ottawa get swiped under
everyone's noses
now to the mystery and investigation
into an art Heist at the Chateau Laurier
in Ottawa this photograph of Sir Winston
Churchill hanging in the hotel's reading
Lounge since 1998 was stolen and swapped
out with a fake about eight months ago
the original one is one of the most
famous portraits of the former British
prime minister and as Dan Spector
explains the copy was so similar nobody
noticed the fame piece was missing until
now
ottawa's storied Chateau Laurier hotel
needs your help to solve a Hollywood
caliber Caper that's captivating art
lovers the world over for us it means
the world since 1998 the hotel's reading
room was home to a unique print of
world-renowned Armenian Canadian
photographer Yusuf karsh's famous
roaring lion picture of former British
prime minister Winston Churchill but
late last week a maintenance worker
noticed it was hanging by a wire instead
of anchors so then we knew it was
probably a copy it was confirmed this
Saturday by The Cars estate longtime
friend and Associate of the late artist
Jerry Fielder took one look and
confirmed the original version gifted to
the hotel by karsh himself had been
swapped out for a fake nobody noticed
for over eight months I think he would
be shocked and amazed and disappointed
that someone would do this
in 1941 as the second world war raged on
European soil Churchill visited Ottawa
delivering a stirring address to the
House of Commons the fight on in unity
together
it was after that speech that the
celebrated photographer captured the
iconic photo that even appears on the
British five pound note the legendary
scowl came after karsh took the cigar
out of Churchill's mouth it became what
we would say today viral this expert in
recovering stolen art says because karsh
lived and worked at the hotel for 20
years the portrait's value is likely in
the six-figure range it's quite possible
that a Insider was involved the hotel
has now removed other famous works as it
re-evaluates security authorities
believe the swap took place between
December 25th and January 6th the hope
is the public can help figure out
exactly when it happened by sharing
photos they may have taken with the
portrait in the background I think
somehow we're going to
find who did it any clues any earring of
somebody trying to sell that portrait we
would love to know karsh's friend says
police have been doing an excellent job
Dan Specter Global News Montreal
out of a movie that's global national
for this Wednesday night I'm Farah
Nasser on behalf of our whole team here
at global national I want to thank you
so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
Burdette Alberta we love seeing your
Canada so please keep emailing us those
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
foreign